what why did I develop this relationship
for the hardest thing that I hated the
here's the thing I hated the most that
year that I was also taking a break - I
was also acting and that was the time
for me to explore if I really wanted to
act or not and what I found out was that
yeah I still want to act
I still enjoy acting I like TV what I
dislike about it is and we hear this
word a lot its politics but that [ __ ] is
so prevalent and if whether you get a
job whether you work how many how much
dick you have to [ __ ] suck in this
industry it's unfuckin real can we just
create art without all this [ __ ]
it's impossible it's so it's so [ __ ]
hard to it's like that's why we try to
be rich though honestly the only reason
why I want to make a [ __ ] ton of money
if I could make art untainted and not
[ __ ] worry about this [ __ ] dude it
would feel great because I would go into
these meetings right and they would be
some some people that I wouldn't meet
they'd go okay so I met like 30 casting
directors right and they go and people
tell me you better remember every single
one of their names I'm like why why how
can I [ __ ] remember thirty of these
[ __ ] names like they were cool
we had a great interaction but I've met
like a gajillion of these people they're
like well they might be giving you oppor
to that's me sucking dick yeah like I
want when I live in the now I have we
had a great conversation you're not
gonna remember everybody but because
this person is somebody who's a
gatekeeper for my career now I have to
force this relationship it's like I
don't want to do that I want to come
into an audition show you what I have
and you booked it off based on that
rather than but that's the game man
that's the part of the game I hate -
yeah but I mean it's a career so you got
to see it as a job interview yeah it's
politics man and I mean that's why you
don't [ __ ] work a nine-to-five job
yeah you know some people can thrive in
that environment and most of us can
that's why we're doing this like I'm
useless in the workplace yeah you know I
mean like yeah but also I'm dangerous in
the workplace because from the last
three companies that I worked at I try
to take it over yeah step aside
[ __ ] from the inside mmm every
single job I've I've got
lazy [ __ ] fired yeah I've I manipulated
the boss to get them fired to kick him
out to do it like I [ __ ] took over
weak bosses they had the title but I was
actually running the show like and I
would do that multiple times and I think
you would do it too it's an
entrepreneurial trait like people that
end up being CEOs or whatever like they
do so because you get sick and tired of
how [ __ ] is being ran and you don't
[ __ ] like it and you don't like your
co-workers cuz to me I want a tight team
I wanna I don't want to walk into a
situation where someone's stealing the
company money by being a lazy [ __ ] yeah
and also to for me I could see that
because even like something small where
people are like yo you can you like you
know how to edit videos you know how to
use After Effects all this stuff like
don't don't other people do that for you
it's like yeah they can but the reason
why I've learned to do it myself is
because I don't want somebody that give
me [ __ ] and then for me to just
simply because I don't know how to work
this oh yeah oh well it's not gonna work
because of this isn't that and I'll be
like which I've had run into this before
where it would be like a video I need
edited and like you know this video is
gonna take like you know like two weeks
to edit and I look at that I'm like no
no it's not and like I was like if you
don't know how to edit this simple
sketch which doesn't require much color
editing in all interval just chopping
and then using like my plural eyes to
sync up to sync up the sound which you
are going to use because you because the
long story short this editor was like
telling me that he goes oh yeah it just
takes time to sync up the audio which is
lazy it's like [ __ ] there's something
called PluralEyes like you know about
pluralizing you're literally saying that
because you want to get the job done in
two weeks and get paid now oh and you
know like I'm letting them know about
the app you're like oh [ __ ] this guy
knows what he's talking about it's like
yeah you're trying to [ __ ] take
advantage of me
and so this is why I like to learn my
things yeah you got it though yeah most
good business owners know their business
from top to bottom yeah it's like you
can't you can't you can't pull the
[ __ ] you know what are the sheep's
wool over my eyes like yeah I know
what's going on yeah but it's pretty
important to have a dream you could take
team you could trust
don't you built that then you can trust
that they'll find people that can I
would well - yeah it's it's it's super
important to because like even like when
I work with other companies and they
give me bull
[ __ ] it's so easy to call out and I and
I [ __ ] hate it when somebody who is
in a higher position they try to say
some [ __ ] because they think you don't
know any better and it's like but you
got to be political David you can't just
cuz I'll call them out when it's the
right thing to do like I mean you're
great at mafia just put it in the
workplace and put it we'll put it in put
it in that space cuz for me like when it
comes to business
that's a game yeah so I don't take
anything personal man like like
sometimes I have fun [ __ ] with people
because they're [ __ ] but I don't
know like you know a lot of it is like I
feel untouchable too because I don't
work for anyone yeah and you know you
can go into a room boardroom and talk
some [ __ ] and do and I have which I've
done to someone one of my guilty
pleasures is um [ __ ] ignoring old men
when in a boardroom
if they start bullshitting me if they
start Hollywood big [ __ ] me in the
middle of what they're saying I would
start talking to someone next to them
they [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] yeah you
don't get they'll don't talk talk talk
talk talk and you don't give them
attention and you [ __ ] cut them off
and start talking to their buddy and
give them more attention they don't know
what to do and I love seeing their
[ __ ] look in that face you know like
you just disrespect I was talking here
hey hey and it's like I'm gonna ignore
this [ __ ] I don't care if you work
with so and so and so and so and so so
in the middle of that I will cut them
off dude and that's the thing is like
that's my pride talking cuz I enjoy
doing it it's like I'm getting horny
watching them doing that okay it's like
I mean I that's the biggest why we
decided to really invest in ourselves
like even like doing the food businesses
that we started it was like how come we
keep taking paychecks these small
paychecks to promote other people's
businesses and yeah we could promote our
own business and create something dope
exactly and it's a long-term thing
something that we care about because
eventually there's gonna be a day when
we all stop doing brand deals you know
and that's when you know that we either
sold the company we made millions of
dollars or you know they're doing so
good that we don't need to do brand
deals yeah everything is a balancing act
yeah
so what are some of your goals for
next year well I think I want to do do
more things that are rewarding to my
soul these past several years I'm going
through this part of my life where I've
worked work worked for things that I
thought were passions but in reality it
was opportunities so mmm you know like
you get an opportunity to make six
figures and you can't read you can't
turn that down you know but now I will
now it's not about the money I'm pretty
comfortable I don't work for money
anymore
what I do now work for is the service of
people and what I mean by that is like
specifically fans right so you know I
have my jemaldin Academy yeah because I
really believe that there's so many just
basic level life skills [ __ ] that's cool
and most people's parents should teach
them but what's mind-blowing to me is
not a lot of people know basic finance
basic credit card how the [ __ ] they
don't even know how credit cards work
just not only that like how to get a job
like people don't know how to get a job
in the field that they want how to make
a killer resume how to [ __ ] interview
and win like they don't know how to like
make side money and not just like
finance they don't have good social
skills there's so much life skill [ __ ]
that they don't know what to do and
that's really rewarding to me because
it's already been open like three months
yeah and a lot of people are going
through it and they're showing me the
results of what they went through and
not only that I'm digging through all of
my old messages and the other day I saw
this one girl she had a catering company
and she messaged me in 2015 and then I
saw recently she messaged me again in
2019 and I never responded back but in
the first message she was like hey I'm
kind of interested I want to build a
business I'm inspired by you guys 20-19
she's like oh [ __ ] I was going through
my messages don't know if you're gonna
read this but I actually ended up
opening up two restaurants yeah and it's
all thanks to you guys your podcast your
videos and to me I was like this is what
I want to do it's so [ __ ]
rewarding to me to see the people that
are watching us and then they build
their own [ __ ] and a lot of the people
that I work with to our fans yeah or I
wouldn't call them fans men they're my
friends but they and but they you know
they grew up either watching me or they
were inspired or whatever right and then
they they make a life for themselves
yeah we somehow find each other just by
mutual friends or whatever and they're
like amen I watched your [ __ ] I used to
watch it all the time and we start
talking we hit it off before you know it
we're working on something together or
something you know whatever and yeah
like one of my partners for jemaldin
Academy you know we met at a karate camp
and alex is helping me out building the
whole entire business and so I think
this is my next phase in life which is
like yes I have my JK yes I have my
writing I films I have all this stuff
but it's really true now I know why Bill
Gates or like when people get ballin
the next stage in their life what they
want to do is help other people you know
cuz that kind of [ __ ] it's it's a
different kind of feeling I mean you
know when you go do [ __ ] meet and
greets and all that right and you meet
the fans and then they tell you their
story of what they went through based
off of you